Good morning, John, it's Wednesday, December 4th
and today I'm gonna to try fit in 51 jokes into one four minute video.
So obviously we should probably get started.
What did one snowman say to the other snowman?
*inhales*
smells like carrots.
What do you get when you throw a hand grenade into a French bathroom?
Linoleum Blownapart.
What's red and smells like blue paint?
Uhh, red paint.
What is the difference between a coyote and a flea?
One howls on the prairie and one prowls on the hairy.
What did one wall say to the other wall?
Let's meet up in the corner.
How come seagulls live by the sea?
Because if they lived by the bay, they'd be bagulls.
Why do cows wear bells?
Cause their horns don't work.
What do you call a nosy pepper?
Jalapeño business.
How come the man driving a train got struck by lightning?
Well, he was a good conductor.
What's the difference between camping and molestation?
Uhhh, I don't know.
Well, since you don't know do you wanna go camping this weekend?
How does Snoop Dog wash his whites?
Bleeatch.
What happened to the magical tractor?
It turned into a field.
What do vegetarian zombies say?
Graaaaaaaaaaaains
Time flies like an arrow...
and fruit flies like a banana
What's brown and sounds like a bell?
Dung!
How does Luke Skywalker get through the forest?
He walks.
Why did the algae and the fungus get married?
They took a lichen to each other.
*sheepish grin*
What do you get when you put a sheep on a trampoline?
A wooly jumper.
How do you fit five bulbasaurs and two charizards onto a bus?
You poke 'em on
Why did the cowboy have a wiener dog?
Cause somebody told him to get a long little doggy.
*Hank laughs at his own joke*
How do you get an 80 year old woman to yell f**k?
You get another 80 year old right next to her to yell, "bingo!"
What does a teenage boy have in common with the enzyme helicase?
They both want to unzip your jeans.
What did the egg say to the boiling water?
"It'll be a minute before I get hard, I just got laid by a chick."
Luke Skywalker and Darth Vader are locked in mortal combat...
...Darth Vader pulls Luke close to him...
(my microphone!)
Darth Vader pulls Luke close to him and says
"I know what you're getting for Christmas"
*Darth Vader breathing*
(Luke:) "What? How? That's impossible!"
(Darth Vader:) "I felt your presence"
Why do chicken coops only ever have two doors?
Cause if they had four doors, they would be a chicken sedan.
What's the difference between a bad golfer and a bad skydiver?
one goes, *whack* "darn!"
and the other goes, "darn!" *whack*
I tried to build an irony detector, but the darn thing just won't work.
Oh, why, what's wrong with it?
It detects everything except irony.
What did the dog say when he sat on some sandpaper?
"Ruff!"
A duck walks into a bar wearing one shoe...
the bartender says, "he lost a shoe!"
and the duck says, "no, I found one!"
What is black and white and black and white and black and white and black and white and black and white and black and white and black and white...
a penguin rolling down a hill.
What's black and white and laughing?
The penguin that pushed him.
After giving up on being a nanny, Mary Poppins actually moved to Beverly Hills and became a fortune teller
and she reads your future, not by looking at the lines on your hand, but by smelling your breath!!!
They call her the Supercaliforniamysticexperthalitosis.
How many Dragon Ball Z characters does it take to change a lightbulb?
Just one, but it's going to take about six episodes.
How many kids with ADD does it take to change a lightbulb?
LET'S GO RIDE BIKES!
What do you get when you drop a piano down a mineshaft?
A flat minor.
Why did the tomato blush?
Cause it saw the salad dressing.
What's the difference between deer nuts and beer nuts?
Beer nuts are $1.50 and deer nuts are under a buck.
What's worst than finding a worm in your apple?
Genocide?
What kind of pants do the Mario brothers wear?
Denim, denim, denim.
I was feeling sad; my friend came up and told me ten jokes to try and make me feel better.
Unfortunately, no pun in ten did.
Why can't Hellen Keller drive?
Because she's DEAD!
Did you hear about the red ship and the blue ship that collided?
All of the sailors were marooned!
How can you tell if it takes Hank more than one day to make a video?
Because the lighting completely changes in the middle!
Two peanuts were walking down the street...
one was assaulted!
What did the zero say to the eight?
"Nice belt!"
A baby seal walks into a club...
*nervous laughter*
What do you call a monkey in a minefield?
A babboom!
What did the YouTuber say when he came in fifth place in a race?
"FIRST!"
If I have one little green ball in one hand, and another little green ball in the other hand,
what do I have?
The undivided attention of a leprechaun.
Why is your sex life like a vlogbrothers video?
Because it never lasts more than four minutes.
51 jokes!
Put your jokes down there, I might do this again!
And my favorite joke that gets put in the next two days will get a free signed copy of my CD!